welcome to the latest episode of just
getting started
my good friend jake tapper who's got a
new book out called the devil may dance
is today's guess
i have a very supportive wife and two
children
and they don't really care
about what work hardship i might have
just endured
it could be frustrating and and
certainly the last few years have been
very frustrating because um of all the
lying
um but beyond that um
i go home and my you know my kids are
completely in kidland uh
and my wife is in their world and also
you know what she does and dealing with
her family members or whatever and
and so it's the perspective is always
there the perspective of
uh that's great that you're on tv but
um you know we have a we have a spanish
test to study for
you know that's important and that's
really
helpful um because it's much more
important in the minds of these people
who i love so much
all right i love having friends on and
great friends at that and highly
successful
friends who have uh who have made
themselves who they are today
and that is how i bring in uh one of the
best from cnn
and i'm holding up a copy of his book as
well the devil may dance the latest
novel from jake tapper right here on
just getting started
how are you jake tapper i'm good my
friend
and uh people should know that that's
not just uh
showbiz bs no you you and i have a
genuine
love and affection for one another i see
you and i'm true
i really i really am crazy about you i
really i really think you're a wonderful
guy
i really do it's true and we go way back
we do
we do this podcast it's about origin
stories and i guess we should start with
ours
in a way was it was it the late 90s when
uh a mutual friend my fellow sports
center anchor at the time brett haber
uh got us all together one night in
washington dc is that is that one that
was
something like that it feels like it was
the late night it feels like it
i feel i feel like i wrote for
washington city paper at the time
is that possible i don't know you might
have been with slate
actually were you when were you salon oh
god i forgot when were you with salon
my bad what was that slalon
like uh 99 to 2002
that's it that's it that's when we met
but i mean like you were so far i don't
even know what event we were
at brett's i don't remember either a
college classmate of mine
and i was friends with him and uh his
his lovely now ex-wife jennifer
uh great woman and you were so
funny that night they had these like
fried potato things at this event
right and you kept calling them latkes
like
mispronounced of mispronunciation of
latkes
as you as a i think you had a girlfriend
at the time or
you didn't have a wife did you uh not in
the late 90s no
not in the late 90s you were helping me
meet a girl
named tammy that i ended up dating
briefly but you you were help
you were assisting you were you're like
the best wingman a guy could have
you were you literally were trying to
make her laugh and get her to to talk to
me
do you remember that i do remember that
and uh
you know and it was a heck of a night
and i had no idea that it actually
worked out even in the slightest way for
you jake
for poor tammy we can't we can't say
that's true
uh she got she got the fuzzy under the
lollipop on that one but
but uh but for me it did and um
yeah i mean uh yeah so that's our origin
story and then
and then we kind of kept in brief touch
and then i think we reacquainted
ourselves through a charity event we do
every year the big slice
right that's when we kind of yeah in
kansas city
what uh yes that is when we we did kind
of reconnect
in person uh in kansas city
yeah we emailed we emailed but it was
the first time yeah did
absolutely and i guess before we get
into
um your actual professional origin story
i think i need to point out for or have
you at least point out
for those who watch this podcast on
uh on my youtube stream on the rich eyes
and show youtube stream
uh what in the hell is happening to your
office
behind you for such a successful man
um there's i mean there's like a coat
rack a small little
that looks like a um that you put
together yourself a little
it's not it's not black are those
supplements
next to an empty coffee can behind it's
protein
it's protein for a protein shake i do
have a i do have protein shakes that's
the um our friend our mutual friend paul
rudd uh when i was trying to lose weight
he put me on the uh
the diet that he went on uh to get an
ant-man shape
um and and part of that is uh
two protein chicks uh late morning and
and late afternoon
so you're uh you're in the park like
there's a tb-12 system in
in the national football league you're
on the you're on the you're on the pr
ant-man the paul rudd ant-man um
well yeah i mean like if he's i'm you
know i'm more like a kind of like a
uh like a cockroach
maybe like if he's the anime i'm i'm
i'm not as i i will say i'm not as
devoted or dedicated
right to it like i'm really good on that
on the polaroid diet
until you know like 7 00 p.m all right
which is not
that's not really how diets work anyway
um
so um but no they're doing construction
yes uh on the my entire floor
uh of cnn so i came in after
they let us come back into the offices
and all my stuff's involved these
these aren't even but you see these
boxes right here these aren't even boxes
of my stuff this is somebody else's
stuff are those just
over here um but normally there's a
little bit more rhyme and reason
and the and the tie rack is you know
it's everything's in storage
i don't know what's going on and i don't
know when i'm getting anything back
and i have no control over everything
but i do have ties
and shirts and you've got this book how
about this
and how about how about that first segue
there we go i got the uh the devil may
dance right here
um for for everybody you've got oh you
have a copy too
you have a copy too and uh i i
you know and i want to get to that in a
minute but i want your origin story
first
how how did you start how did you get
started jake tapper how does somebody
get to
be on the career path that you are still
following
right you know what's so funny and so
okay so i'm uh we're going to talk about
my origin story as a journalist not as a
an author because uh my fault right
because i full time
no i mean we'll get to that because you
you're clearly what you're doing
um i guess your day job your night job
or whatever
that is it's it's something that you
love to do but you're also
trying else something new as well which
i'd want to delve into that but before
we get to
all of that as a as an awesome yes how
did you
how did you start because we talked
about salon even though i called it
slate before uh
that's okay those were i mean those were
every time no you're a newsman you have
to you're about facts you're about facts
jake
and they came up at the same time and
slate's still like around and thriving
in salon i'm not sure what salon's doing
anymore but anyway um
the truth of the matter is that it's
kind of odd that i didn't
think about going into journalism until
my mid-20s because it was
part of my life from the very beginning
i am actually named after my dad's great
uncle
who was a managing editor at the chicago
sun times
and i did like a like a newspaper for
our neighborhood when i was a kid
and i was editor of the school paper in
high school and all this stuff
but then i just had no interest in it i
guess when i went to college i
started i wanted to be a cartoonist
long story short um i end up
in my mid-20s having no idea what i
wanted to do with my life
and i was on a ski trip with some
friends
and one of the friends was holding a
copy of the new republic magazine
which in the 90s was just like it was
the hottest coolest
and most interesting like michael lewis
wrote for them it was just a great
magazine
and there was a story in there by uh a
couple guys that my friends knew
and it was like a light bulb going off
like oh my god like actual
people that we know just like come up
with ideas and write
freelance stories and magazines
and and it was just like a revelation to
me
and i started doing freelance writing
for anyone
that would publish me anyone the
dartmouth alumni magazine i pitched
something to entertainment weekly and
just like i just
i didn't know enough to not be as
bold as i was and just pitching and
pitching and pitching
anyway a few years later i have a ton of
clips and
washington city paper hired me and from
there it was just a matter of
washington city paper to salon
[Music]
i would then when i was at salon i
started doing some tv stuff here and
there for cnn and
others and then i really kind of got the
bug
the tv thing i was doing freelance
writing but
i went to start learning about tv
eventually i put together a reel and
then i went to abc news
that was a whole sink or swim
environment but i was there for nine
years
and then worked my way up to cnn
offering me my own show to anchor
and i came here in 2013. what do you
mean what do you mean by sink or swim
jake what do you mean by that
oh well just abc news was tough it was
just it was just a it was a very
competitive environment there were very
few minutes in the day
uh the way that the place i don't know
what it's like now but the way that the
place was
um set up at the time was
uh so that you were just constantly
competing with other journalists to get
on air um
it wasn't like you know here's 10
reporters and like
you know there wasn't some benevolent
leader saying and we're going to make
sure everybody gets on air three times a
week
yes you know it was it was it was like
it was like a
a news room imagine a newsroom of a
newspaper
but it's only one page a day right it
was that kind of thing
like you're just you know constantly
competing so it's just
um i wasn't the prettiest and i wasn't
the sharpest broadcaster and i wasn't
uh you know the only thing i could do is
pitch the best ideas
and break them up and break the the most
stories and that's it i mean that's
it it was just based on work ethic
because it could be based on i mean
there were people that were much
smoother on television
there were people that were like you
know underwear model
good looking and uh and then there was
me
and all i could do was work the hardest
pitch the most creative ideas break the
break stories
you know and so that's what i did and it
worked was that when
was peter jennings still there i mean
was that there
yeah what was he here uh what was he
when i started at abc news
yeah it was just i mean it was it was
diane sawyer and charlie gibson in the
morning
robin roberts did the news uh
peter jennings in the evening and ted
koppel doing nightline
at night at 11 30. and um
you know it was a dream and i was with
giants of the industry
and uh you know they're all retired or
in peter's case
uh passed away uh i think as diane's in
semi
retirement she still does pieces for abc
news every now and then still has
specials
but i mean it was just a very
competitive
place um
and uh yeah i want to pause my
conversation with jake tapper for a
moment to talk about my friends at grove
collaborative
we can all agree i'm sure that running
to the store
has been very stressful lately for
months there's nothing worse than
forgetting something on your list and
needing to make multiple trips
shopping for home essentials should be
easy and that's where grove
collaborative does come in
grove is the online marketplace that
delivers healthy home beauty and
personal care products directly to you
with grove you don't have to shop
multiple stores or search endlessly
online to get all the natural goods you
need
for you and your family plus shipping is
fast and free
on your first order join over 2 million
households who have trusted grove
collaborative to make their homes
happier
and healthier for a limited time when my
listeners go to grove.co
eisen you'll get to choose a free gift
with your first order of thirty dollars
or more
making the switch to natural products
has never been easier for a limited time
when my listeners go to grove dot co
slash eisen
you'll get to choose a free gift with
your first order of thirty dollars or
more but you have to use our special
code
go to grove.co eisen to get your
exclusive offer
that's grove dot co slash eisen
i remember when i first got to espn
robin roberts was there
too she was on the the early evening
sportscenter
and i was just so
taken aback that i was thrown in the
midst
of all of these people who i watched on
television
and trying to figure out my own way at
that point in time was
pretty damn daunting i mean i didn't
have to work to get on the i mean
i was scheduled to do sportscenter like
that was
i didn't have to like what you're
talking about kind of have to sing for
your supper to get on the air because
there were so many people just trying to
get on one show in a way
you know and i'm wondering if how
pressurized that must have been for you
at the time well i mean think about it i
mean for um first of all
we should say i guess your your viewers
and listeners know your origin story but
i mean like you were there at a time
keith olbermann uh craig kilbourne i
mean
just dance patrick giants right well
it's similar to what you're talking
about arriving at abc news you know what
i'm saying i mean that was
in that regard those were not the people
i'm i was listening were not my peers
they were you know they were the anchors
i was just sure
but it was it was it was real sink or
swim and you know when you're
when you're starting your career you're
an anchor now i'm an anchor now
we're not worried about getting on air
we have our shows
we're worried about making them as good
as possible but we're not worried about
getting on air
but when you are a correspondent getting
on air is like
oxygen and when you're not on air you're
like a fish thrown on the boat
and like you're just like i need i guess
it's the opposite now
if i switch to a oxygen metaphor now
you need it's all right no it's all good
i like it the opposite metaphor now but
my point is like you're flailing
because you're not getting on air what
is your worth and
yeah and it was very very competitive
and and look also like
some very very tough executive producers
and anchors
and senior producers and others i mean
some that were just absolutely lovely
and took a
chance with me the very the very first
person to take a chance with me
at abc news other than the people who
hired me um
was uh with diane sawyer and shelly ross
who is the then legendary producer
executive producer of good morning
america
and they put me on air and again uh it
was
just work ethic
i can tell you exactly what happened my
big break in abc news because you get
hired by abc news that doesn't mean
you're going to succeed at abc news
right
and i saw lots of really good talented
smart people get hired by abc news
and just thrown in the shark tank and
like you just never saw him again and
then three years later the contract was
over and you hear that they were
going to someplace else but i what
happened was i was
um i i was on email
and uh schwarzenegger was going on leno
and uh he announced that he was this is
2003.
he announced that he was going to
uh run uh against gray davis the
governor of california
uh he was going to run against him in
the recall election y'all are having one
of those
out there some of the same candidates
mary kerry god bless her
um anyway i know that i know that's your
favorite i know you've
i know you've maxed out yeah you know
what i mean hey now
cinemax down yes i understand what
you're saying yes yes
that's what i call up anyway sorry i'll
keep it clean
for the kids so uh anyway schwarzenegger
was right so the the transcript comes
out at like
i don't even know seven o'clock eight
o'clock before it airs
at 11 30. this is a different era of
this priest people don't even the kids
listening there's
there were the internet existed but
there were no smartphones no facebook no
twitter
it was basically just email and websites
was how you got information
anyway um hinowski was doing this so i
immediately pitched myself
to uh shelly and diane and their team
i knew enough i was pitch i've been
pitching stories for months
having less and less success but
pitching them anyway i was just like oh
here's an idea
schwarzenegger's running let me do a
piece about this and i will incorporate
classic schwarzenegger film lines
in this piece i don't think
any of this exists somewhere but i don't
even think that was i don't even think
the pitch was it
i think it was just the fact that
anybody was pitching this to them that
anybody was like
this just happened i want to be on air i
want to tell the story let me tell the
story
i'm here i'll work through the night you
know i'm ready and i always tell young
people
like you have to have something that
they want nobody's going to
give you a job to be nice you have to
have something that you that they want
and it might just be that you're willing
to get up at two in the morning and do
whatever the hell
you know what i mean it might just be
work ethic sure that's what i offered
um anyway that became that just i
started doing story after story after
story and the next thing i knew
i was living at the standard in la and
and covering the
the recall for good morning america and
and here you and now here you are
obviously all these years later so
just before we move on and then we'll
get to your book um
so obviously the schwarzenegger total
recall
that was an easy one what uh how how
else did i really would like to go back
and see i'm sure what else did you work
in what else
uh uh i don't know it was none of my
favorites it was none of the
you know audi hauser if you're watching
this you have a towel wrapped around
your head in cool hagen on your ass
probably that probably didn't
okay i don't know how to work that one
in yeah
it's right it's not a tumor okay so you
got a kindergarten job
twins might be something you could work
in i'm just trying to see
obviously you know schwarzenegger with
an act winning a recall that's a
i'm sure i'll be back with part of it i
don't know all right
i'm not saying this was not an audition
for the algonquin roundtable
okay this was i'm not saying that these
are bulma
that i want on my mausoleum someday
all right i was just saying i don't
think this was
this wasn't isaac newton my point was
not that this was a brilliant idea it
was just like
i was just like what do you want me to
do i'm here i'll do it
you know what i mean oh
man all right so let's get to uh some
here and now this book that you have
written yeah
okay um the devil may dance
uh this is your second novel and my
second album but the first one i ever i
first one i wrote that i thought
you know i think rich would really like
this novel well i mean
you know i i read your first novel as
well i know but
and and you were very nice and
complimentary and supportive of course
but you are a sinatra fan
i should hold up the front uh uh this is
this is uh
gonna be my reading when i actually have
time in june because that's what i i
will you know uh
what is that uh uh well i guess that's
life
uh riding high in april shot down in may
but
you know i'm sort of you know that's
that's what i'm saying
i know i'm gonna change that tune when
i'm when i'm back in june which is when
i'm going to release this thank you very
much
that is my karaoke go-to right there so
but you are honestly of everyone i know
yes
and i you know i'm not you know this you
know a lot of people you know a lot of
people i mean paul rudd gave you
supplements for crying out loud
you know i mean but he did actually
recommend that brand
um but but the no but of all the people
i know and you know
that i am as just as insecure as the
next person
uh you you know that you're being
self-effacing no
no no you know that's true i'm very but
you are the only person
about whom i would say i know you're
gonna love this book
i know i am so confident you're gonna
love this book
because you love sinatra you love the
kennedys
you love you love that era and also just
because you're a supportive friend
you're coming to the table expecting
like with all of your heart all of your
nachos is going to pour into the reading
of the book
all of your nachos and i love the
manchurian candidate and i can't believe
that that's
that is a crucial part of the plot
points of this
novel so i mean like you you're you're
you're
nailing all of the touch points for me
it's all your sweet spots it is
like if your wife was a character in the
book then that would be
and your kids that would be the end of
it but it wouldn't make any sense
because it takes place in 1962.
i want to pause my conversation with my
friend jake tapper for just a moment to
tell you about my other friends it's
sleep number
i love my sleep number bed i get my
sleep iq score every single morning just
to know exactly how well i slept
i set my side of the bed to the way i
want my firmness to be
and my wife does the same my sleep
number is 60. hers is 70. it's just 10
numbers apart
but it really does mean the world of
difference and getting proven quality
sleep from sleep number
means the world of difference as well
because a good night's rest helps boost
immunity increase energy and quality
sleep improves recovery
sleep helps us recover faster from
exercise injuries and
illnesses deep sleep decreases anxiety
overnight
by recognizing connections in the brain
rem sleep is essential for many of the
brain's cognitive and emotional function
since most of it happens during the
second half of the night so it's
important
to get seven to nine hours of sleep
discover
proven quality sleep with sleep number
save one thousand dollars on the new
sleep number 360 special edition smart
bed during the memorial day sale
only at sleep number stores or sleep
number dot com
eisen don't forget the slash eisen
sleepnumber.com
eisen
[Applause]
why do you want to write a novel why do
you want to do this now twice
what why jake not only do i want to
write a novel
i want you to write a book and i've
pitched you your own book
i've told you this is what you wrote so
i know you have
no i know and that's why you're such a
great friend i know everybody's gonna
read it i know i'm too busy doing i'm
too busy
doing stuff like this that's why i can't
understand
how you have time you cover like the
election of our
lifetimes you are all over
well but i don't know how you do that
like i'm i'm covering
an nfl season and then doing this
podcast
and then you know i have three kids
i mean you're a dad that's what it is
is that right i only have two this is
your third baby right here
right there's your third baby you know
the only thing i can say is first of all
people like you and i and probably a lot
of your your listeners and viewers
you know we're we're a little type a
we're you know we're very driven
we're very very driven people and i
really i really like writing
and um now i'm doing journalism and i
love journalism
but i also love writing and it brings me
joy and it also is a
welcome escape for me
from the non-stop
nastiness death and destruction that
i've been covering for the last
period of time so it's enjoyable
for me this was fun because
i what inspired the book
was a story that you're probably
familiar with which is
in 1960 sinatra and the rat pack
worked their hearts out for president
kennedy
senator kennedy to get elected president
right and
sinatra who is a friend of the president
uh then expects that john f kennedy
president kennedy will stay with him
when he comes and visits out by your way
at some point during his presidency
the sinatra this is he has an estate in
rancho mirage
at this point it's not the later estate
he has in palm springs this is rancho
mirage he calls it the compound
and he starts to build it up this is a
real story this is not my fiction uh
builds rooms installs telephone lines
has it has a helipad built
so that president kennedy can stay with
him
and at the same time attorney general
robert kennedy
is investigating organized crime and
it becomes pretty apparent to him that
sinatra
is friends with a lot of the people he's
investigating
namely sam g and kana but also johnny
handsome johnny roselli from los angeles
and others
so this becomes a decision that robert
kennedy has to make
do i piss off frank sinatra one of the
biggest stars in the world who helped my
brother get elected or
do i let my brother stay at a place
where mobster's
frequent and that's the premise and
inspiration for the book i have in my
book
attorney general kennedy basically
blackmails charlie and margaret the
heroes of my first book
yes to go out and investigate to see if
sinatra's really mobbed up
and the and the premise is that
charlie is a world war ii hero and a
politician he's a congressman
so he'll be a consultant on the
manchurian candidate which they're
filming
right at that point so
did sold right no of course i'm
look again the hellfire club was so
phenomenal
and um and this i can't i honestly again
i'm not just saying it because you're a
friend and a guest and
all of that stuff and i do love you i
cannot wait
to you know crack this book and i hope
to have like a week's time to just
do nothing but just curl up with jake
tapper in writing style and
and um and you'll finish it in you'll
finish it in a weekend
but beyond that let me also say i would
like to curl up with you thank you for
that
but that's but that's a separate issue
like a spoon so do you that's what i'm
saying is like i i i could be the front
spoon or the backspin i am i am
i am totally in awe jake because i know
what you must be
what you must go through to do your show
every day and then go
home and put it aside to just be a dad
and a husband
and then put that aside to be a novelist
i
cannot fathom the the brain equity
it requires and discipline it must
require did you ever have a point where
like
i am not riding today i just don't have
it in me like i just i i can't i'm going
to put it down i'm going to stop
because that could be obviously a death
blow
because you have to keep going to keep
writing
because of energy there were times that
i wrote myself into a corner
uh in terms of the plot that i thought
oh [ __ ] i don't know how i'm gonna get
out of this um
and and i took a few days to like
you know marinate but there wasn't like
you know an attack on the capital that
took you
i guess you were finished writing it one
time right so when did you finish this
during the election during the actual
election where did you finish it
when did you send your last pages and it
was locked i think last summer at the
end of last summer
no uh yeah labor day
by labor day it was done but also let me
just add like
yes i had the presidential election to
cover and my
my day job is busy and all that but
last year uh from
the april to august i was broadcasting
from home
so that's an hour and a half commute
that you don't have
also you know this when you're in the
office how much of your time
is wasted because people are popping in
your office
talking to you right now i mean it's not
wasted it's you know it's
level i understand what you're saying
yes but but time that that's
you could spend doing other things also
in a normal election year i'd be
traveling all over the place
iowa new hampshire south carolina
battleground state battleground state
debate
uh last year uh after the
pandemic hit um
i i made i did two trips the whole year
for work
two one time we flew to michigan to
interview biden
and another time after he won i drove to
wilmington
to interview him and vice president
harris but so i i
the truth is in 2020 i had a lot more
openings in my calendar than i normally
would interesting
oh man and now you're back in the office
and they stick you in a closet i don't
know what's going on with them man
i i don't understand i would uh feel
like groundskeeper willie is going to
show up with a giant mop
do you have uh already a third novel
idea picked out or you just got to tap
out i have a setting
i have a third novel setting so the
first book is in the is in the 50s
this book uh the devil my dance is in
the 60s so i think i'm going to do the
70s
now my publisher is eager for me to
um maybe uh
i think i'm going to do charlie and
margaret's son his they have two kids
uh lucy and dwight i think dwight who
will be
1819 in the mid 70s
might be a fun main character
to have because charlie and margaret are
like i mean charlie's troubled but he's
a
they're good people but maybe i could do
something of a
kind of like a badass kind of like an
anti-hero i don't know that might be fun
you're a disco that's was asked what
what 70s mid 70s like
disco bg's disco carter's roll into town
everything's crazy
studio 54.
and then out to keep with staff is
rumored to be doing lines in the studio
54 that happened
and he denies it i should know you you
it's kind of a wild time so i guess
uh you know putting this all to bed
what advice would you give to somebody
if they like me
saying i don't know if i have time for
that i mean honestly
uh you have given me an idea for a book
it would require
your stories for your stories i'm just
saying put them in a book
no i don't worry i've already done a
book jake and it was a book about the
launch of nfl network and it took so
much
out of me and so like what you're doing
right now like coming on this pod and
you know i understand
you know we're friends or whatever but
you just finished you know
two hours of your show and now you're
sitting
in your in your office uh right for the
moment
and in my life in your office you know
it's air quotes
um if somebody came in right now
and just picked up a giant thing of
toilet paper
would it surprise you no it would not it
would so two things
but i mean honestly so you know
here's okay i'm going to answer your
question first of all people should know
the book that i tried to and that i that
you and i talked about yes
you tell these great stories about
athletes
uplifting stories yes amazing stories
amazing uplifting stories
and i just said just like get 12 of them
put them in a book
bang right it's enough the amount of
research that is required and for you to
find
time to do all of that i don't
understand you can hire a researcher by
the way i mean that that
is allowed anyway moving on from that
yes
okay two um my
uh advice in terms of time allocation
and
making yourself right is you have to
commit to yourself
the same way you commit uh when you lose
weight
uh or when you go on a diet or when you
get fit or whatever you commit i'm gonna
five days a week i'm gonna hit the
peloton or whatever
five days a week i'm gonna run and you
just you have to make that promise to
yourself
and my promise is when i write um
what and i'm not writing right now but
when i'm in a writing
zone yes i'm gonna write every day
for 15 minutes that's it for 15 minutes
because everybody can find 15 minutes in
their schedule breakfast
lunch dinner right before you go to bed
whatever you can find 15 minutes
if you commute uh you know on the subway
or whatever you just bring your laptop
with you 15 minutes
so that's doable and if that's all you
do
at the end of the week that's an hour 45
minutes that's four pages
that's that's not nothing that's good so
that's how i do it and then the third
thing is
i would say um i outline
a book before i write it
and i think that really helps uh in
terms
of getting me because it's like okay
what am i writing now oh i have to write
this chapter where these five things
happen
that really helps me and some people
write differently
some people are are george rr martin
from game of thrones he has this thing
called uh you're either a gardener or an
architect
gardeners just kind of go out and plant
and see what happens and i'm definitely
an architect i have the plans
for me that's very helpful because i
have this outline and i just
follow it and then you know uh
another another writing tip that i read
from somebody
uh a legendary writer for the simpsons
he just did a q a in the new yorker that
was fantastic and his whole thing is
get the script done first even if it's
crap and then you can go and rewrite it
and make it good but the main thing is
to have the structure
so those are the tips that have always
worked for me
i think they would i don't think like
i'm no i guess it's just again it's just
but i think that's it's it's sound
advice just in anything it doesn't
have to be writing that if you give
10-15 minutes of your day
to something else whether even if it's
charitable work whether it's something
else that can actually enlighten your
life or enrich it in a way that makes
you feel like you're doing something
that's
that's some sound advice today's episode
of just getting started with jake tapper
is brought to you by
geico do you own or rent your home sure
you do and i bet it can be hard work
you know what's easy bundling policies
with geico
geico makes it easy to bundle your
homeowners or renters insurance along
with your auto policy
it's a good thing too because you
already have so much to do around your
home
go to geico.com get a quote and see how
much you could save it's geico
easy visit geico.com today that's
geico.com
[Applause]
this is a legit question and i i don't i
think i may have asked you this like on
the back of a bus
heading to uh you know the big slick
celebrity uh
once again the big slick uh that's where
we go that's where we that's where we
we had this conversation about the book
like it it shouldn't be virtual and
you and i should i mean that's not for
me no i know we knock on wood
i really look forward to seeing you next
year exactly so last one last thing for
you is
how you know because i i deal with this
a lot and i'm sure a lot of people deal
with it in their jobs as well
where they they do hear [ __ ] they
hear it they know it they could smell it
it's coming their way i get spun all the
time on my show i know
somebody you know this it's not life or
death it is sports although it's very
serious for a lot of people people get
killed in sports
how do you how do you deal with that
when you know in politics you're being
spun doesn't matter what side of the
aisle it is
and then you go home sometimes i'll text
you after a sunday because i
i'm on the air on a sunday morning on
foot on my football sundays and my
twitter feed is filled with what goes on
on the sunday morning shows and i do see
your
back and forths uh and my twitter feed
and i think to myself my god you know
um how when you go home do you do you
sit
do you decompress what do you what do
you do how do you
how do you deal with that after you deal
with uh that high wire act on live
television
jake i um
well i i think it's probably very
similar to you which is
uh i have a very supportive wife
and two children and they don't
really care about
what work hardship i might have just
endured
because as you note
it's not like i'm going through the pain
it's it's i'm having an
interview where i'm trying to get
somebody to admit something or whatever
but it's not it's not it could be
frustrating and and certainly the last
few years have been
very frustrating because of all the
lying
um but beyond that um
i go home and my you know my kids are
completely in kidland uh
and my wife is in their world and
also you know what she does and dealing
with
her family members or whatever and and
so
it's the perspective is always there the
perspective of
uh that's great that you're on tv but
um you know we have a we have a spanish
test to study for
you know that's important and that's
really
helpful um because it's much more
important in the minds of these people
who i love so much
and so and tv as you know the other
thing about tv is it's ephemeral and we
all get to
try again tomorrow like so if i have a
bad day or i mess up or whatever or i do
something not as well as i wish i had or
an interview doesn't go the way i i
wanted it to have
i get to try again tomorrow so
none of that stuff really matters all
that much it's my
what i cover matters but my role in it
doesn't right
and then i i get upset when i see what
people say about the way you handle your
business and i i know you
and i'll say this i you know i i know
you
you are literally the straightest
shooter i know and you are
of somebody i i texted you uh on
occasion during
uh some of the most important stories of
our lifetimes that you covered and you
were there
and the way you handled it and i know
but it just pisses me off when people
think that you have an agenda and i
you you are like the most a genderless
person that i
know it's interesting even me
instagraming out reading your book you
know the responses i get
it pisses me off and you know
um i just wanted to say that for anybody
that's out here
right now watching or listening you
uh honestly i i know you and there's so
many people in this world certainly in
the world of sports where
you know you think you know somebody and
you really don't i really do
you're like one of the few people where
i could swear that you are who you are
and i know you're not
somebody who i don't think you are and
um i just
kind of wanted to say that you know well
you're very kind and i am who i am
for better and for worse and yeah i mean
it bums me out too but by the same token
i mean i know a lot of people
have been have had their brains broke
in the last few years just by by lying
or the
reactions to the lying i mean there was
a great new york times story
by ben smith about this crazy conspiracy
theory that this poor guy
on jeopardy who had had won three
episodes in a row of jeopardy was doing
like some sort of white supremacist sign
and he was not
and i mean it just shows you
that it's not there is so much
disinformation and misinformation and
mistrust in this society where does
people just
there's this you and i are of the
hebraic tradition
and and there's a and michael medved the
conservative
um radio host yes uh taught me
uh uh one of the last times i did a show
he taught me this
um great concept in judaism
which is don the cops include or like in
yiddish it would be your
your bubby would say or something like
that but
in any case the point is giving people
the benefit of the doubt
that's that's the whole notion giving
somebody the benefit of the doubt
does this person
should we really just assume that he's
putting up a white supremacist
sign on jeopardy should we really run
there
and like so much of social media and
today's politics it's like people
just assuming the worst about every now
look sometimes people
prove themselves over time to not be
worth the benefit of the doubt and
and and that's okay but i just feel like
there's so little
in our world uh where people
can give each other the benefit of the
doubt so the stuff
that you talk about and it's from the i
assume in your in your replies it's
it's from trump supporters these days
but like during the obama years it would
a lot of times it would be from obama's
supporters would be attacking me
um i you know i would be lying if i said
it didn't
you know on occasion get me down because
i think i'm really
i try to be a good person i'm not saying
i always succeed but i
try i aspire and i really do
try to see the other side of arguments
than from what the narrative is whatever
like i don't automatically assume
that this person is lying or this
person's telling the truth or whatever
whatever i come to it
just trying to find out what the facts
are because i want my viewers to know
what the facts are
and sometimes that's um
i succeed sometimes i fail but i'm
always trying
so it does bum me out yeah well i
i am there for you and as you know a
whole legion of people are there for you
certainly when we're supporting what
you're doing
and this book that i'm holding up again
for the podcast audience the devil may
dance go get it where all books
are sold acquired online in a bookstore
um you are the best jake tapper thank
you for doing this podcast i really
appreciate it rich i love you i'll talk
to you soon my friend
you bet and we actually got through a
conversation without the whole die hard
thing being brought up
so you just brought it up well you just
you
just i guess right away i i guess in a
gateway just to wrap this up you're
somebody who says it's a christmas movie
i'm or or
and i say it is not um i just on my own
instagram
uh the other night there was a a little
big
jenga tower uh that we we put together
with my kids
and i just took a shot of it you know
and somewhat disarray and i said it did
look like a tower
and i i just basically said welcome to
the party pal hashtag nakatomi jenga
and uh only one person responded with uh
an emoji and that would be you jake
tapper a christmas tree
so technically you were the last one who
could not leave it alone
i didn't know that you saw my emoji i
did i i actually hearted it but that's
okay that's the way we communicate in
this uh 21st century sometimes so
you were the last one to not be able to
leave it alone and i guess now tag
you're it
uh next time you have me on anything or
whatever we'll
do that you take care of jake
all right that's jake tapper right here
on just getting started
clearly i've known jake for some time
and um
and i'm so glad that uh many of you
might for the first time have gotten a
chance to meet the
the man that you see on cnn or you have
a certain
sense of what his takes in the world are
or what his
uh opinions are on the screen and
honestly i
i wanted to bring that up and what
drives me crazy these days
is me bringing something like that up
could be viewed
as offensive to somebody he is
literally the least defensive guy i know
he's a religious man he is a um a man of
many talents and
just he is a dad he is a husband
as what you just heard the most
important role for him
and i just wanted to bring that up and
you know
um it's just interesting how you you
meet people just on an off
chance setting and you never know what
sort of uh
lifelong relationship or friendship that
you may have
and he has brought up a book idea to me
he mentioned it here
uh what what um
what he thought or thinks is gonna be a
best-selling book
and i'll be honest with you i i just
sometimes sit here and think to myself
i don't have time to do anything outside
of what i'm attempting to do every
single day
in a day where things can go so fast and
things
in this world go so out of control this
podcast is about
gaining control of your life and gaining
control of what you can control
or understanding that what you can't
control should not
make you feel like you've lost control
that everything that you want to do with
your life is
inside you it is of you of what you want
and jake is an inspiration in the fact
that
i can't imagine his day being crazier
busier
more filled with uh plans that you have
to scrap
because his day is so
based on current events and current
events change
every minute these days i can't imagine
that he takes the time to actually write
a book
research it and write a book and it's so
terrific and it's so well received
so i guess you know maybe i should put
my nose to the grindstone a little more
or all of us should be out there
thinking hey
just when you think you have enough you
don't have enough time in the day
maybe you've got a little bit more time
and
making sure that when your day
is over taking the extra 10 15
30 minutes out can change
your outlook can change what you can do
for yourself
if you can do something for others with
that time
you know that the phone calls that i
made and time that i made
um in march and april
to make sure that i was able to run for
st jude was a significant amount of time
and it takes a lot out of you but maybe
just maybe all of us should uh
take stock and find out if there is
something extra that we can do
uh for ourselves for our mental state
for our for for others in our lives
it's just uh something to think of that
there's always time in the day
for something that you think is
important for your self-improvement or
that for others
just wanted to mention that that's it
for this episode of just getting started
i want to thank jake tapper again the
devil may dance where all books are sold
go check it out
you will not be sorry that's it for this
episode
we'll see you next wednesday on just
getting started